RUSSIANS.
LAURA?
>> Laura: THANK YOU SO MUCH
ARE PLEASED TO WELCOME AN
EXCLUSIVE FORMER TRUMP CAMPAIGN
ADVISOR CARTER PAGE.
CARTER, IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU
TONIGHT.
MORE THE REACTION TO IT.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION?
>> WELCOME A FIRST REACTION,
LARA, WHEN I SAW IT WAS, YOU
KNOW, THERE WAS A LOT OF DETAILS
THAT KEPT TRIPPING OUT.
IT SOUNDED REALLY BAD.
INTERESTING IS THE NEXT 48 HOURS
AFTER THAT WHERE PART OF THE
ATTACK ON CHAIRMAN NUNES AND THE
COMMITTEE WAS TO COME UP WITH
ANY NEW INFORMATION TO DISCREDIT
ME AND ANYTHING RELATED TO THE
INVESTIGATION OR THE OVERALL
INVESTIGATION AND ALL THE GREAT
WORK THAT HE HAS BEEN DOING.
IT'S PRETTY STARK CONTRAST
BETWEEN GETTING THE FACTS OUT
THERE, HAVING -- STILL GETTING
ATTACKED.
TONIGHT.
ED REFERRED TO THE INTERVIEW HE
DID A SHORT WHILE AGO WITH
TUCKER CARLSON.
HE WAS ASKED ABOUT YOU.
THIS IS WHAT HE SAID.
>> THIS IS A LOW-LEVEL PERSON
THIS PERSON IS NO LONGER WORKING
ON THE CAMPAIGN.
I BELIEVE ONE OF MY FAMILY
MEMBERS RESPONDED, "WHO THE HECK
IS THAT INDIVIDUAL QUESTION MIKE
WE NEVER EVEN HEARD OF HIM."
TO USE THAT, AGAIN, AS THE BASIS
TO THEN TRY TO ATTACK THE DULY
ELECTED PRESIDENT, TO DO IT WHEN
PERSON -- THEY SEEM LIKE A GREAT
PATSY FOR THAT.
>> Laura: YOUR REACTION TO
WHAT DONNIE SAYS, LOW-LEVEL
FIGURE IN THE CAMPAIGN?
I DON'T THINK YOU EVER REALLY
>> WELL.
IT WAS REALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO HELP
OUT IN ANYWAY, BECAUSE AS YOU
WERE ALLUDING TO, THE ATTACKS
STARTED ALMOST IMMEDIATELY.
OR OTHERWISE IN RUSSIA WAS
CONSTANTLY SORT OF THE NUMBER
ONE TARGET FOR ATTACK, SO IT
I WOULD SAY IT THOUGH, AND
ALLUDED TO THIS EARLY FOREIGN
POLICY COMMITTEE, I WAS REALLY
IMPRESSED WITH A LOT OF THE
OTHER PEOPLE THAT WERE ON THE
COMMITTEE.
AS YOU MENTIONED, THERE WAS A
FEW NAMES THAT WERE MENTIONED.
REALLY, THE PEOPLE THAT CAME ON
IN THE EARLY MONTHS WERE PRETTY
INCREDIBLE.
>> Laura: CARTER, THERE WAS
ONLY ONE MEETING THOUGH?
THIS WAS SLEPT TOGETHER IN
24 HOURS.
THROWN TOGETHER PRETTY FAST.
WE'VE GOT TO HAVE A LIST OF
PEOPLE ADVISING US.
INTERNATIONAL, I UNDERSTOOD.
AFTER THAT, THERE WAS NO FORMAL
GATHERING OF THIS GROUP.
I SHOULD'VE CLARIFIED THE ONE
POINT THAT AD HAD ALLUDED TO.
THAT ONE MEETING --
WHERE I'M GETTING AT.
YOU WERE PUT ON THIS LIST AND
YOUR PAST WORK THAT YOU DID IN
RUSSIA, WE'LL GET INTO THAT
LATER, RAISED A RED FLAG.
THE FBI APPARENTLY HAD BEEN
WATCHING YOU FOR SOME TIME.
OKAY.
WE FAST-FORWARD TO JULY.
YOU GO TO MOSCOW.
YOU SAY YOU ARE INVITED TO GIVE
A SPEECH AT A COLLEGE THERE.
WHEN YOU WENT THERE, DID YOU
MEET WITH GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS
OR PEOPLE CONNECTED CLOSELY WITH
THERE WAS ONE SENIOR GOVERNMENT
OFFICIAL WHO SPOKE AFTER ME.
HE WAS WALKING OUT OF THE
BUILDING AFTER HE GAVE HIS
SPEECH.
WE HAD A VERY BRIEF CONVERSATION
FOR LESS THEN TEN SECONDS.
IT WAS REALLY AN EXCHANGE OF
PLEASANTRIES.
YOU KNOW, A LOT OF THE THINGS HE
WAS TALKING ABOUT, YOU CAN TELL
TERMS OF U.S.-RUSSIAN RELATIONS.
>> Laura: WAS THAT IGOR --
JUST SO PEOPLE KNOW, I FIND THIS
TO BE FASCINATING.
IN THIS FAKE DOSSIER, THERE IS
AN ENTIRE PARAGRAPH.
I BELIEVE IT'S ON PAGE 31.
FORMER KGB GUY, PRESIDENT OF
IMPOSED ON THE COMPANY THAT HE
OFFERED PAGE, TRUMP'S ASSOCIATE,
BROKERAGE UP TO 19% PRIVATE IN
STATE ON ROSNEFT, IF TRUMP WERE
THAT'S RIGHT FROM THE DOSSIER,
CARTER.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE HEAR
ABOUT THE DOSSIER DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S IN IT.
YOU ARE SAYING TODAY THAT YOU
NEVER MET IGOR -- I FORGET HIS
NAME, IGOR SECHIN.
>> I'VE NEVER MET HIM.
IF YOU DO THE MATH ON THAT,
-- THAT SEEMS LIKE A PRETTY
HEFTY SUM, YOU KNOW?
>> Laura: THAT'S PRETTY GOOD.
CARTER, HOLD RIGHT THERE.
WE HAVE A LOT MORE TO TALK